um beispielsweise auf socken oder so an
mein name ist herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video von mir hier mal
wieder sehen werde damen und herren sind
sehe ich hier komplett nicht alleine
sondern zusammen mit ihr seht schon im
titel eingeblendet wir machen heute eine
anruf halten challenge und zwar
ehrenamtlich hier schon haben
ich habe schon zwei zettel vorbereitet
einer vom max corp einer von meinem kopf
und die kleben wird sich ein kopf
sondern wir schreiben für den anderen
begriffe drauf die er bei einem anruf
mit einem unternehmen einbringen muss
und wenn möglich müssen alle drin sein
nicht schlecht erklärt was könnte ich
das schreibunterlage verwenden bestes
schreibunterlage 2000 jahre später wir
haben uns jetzt jeder gegenseitig zehn
begriffe haufen blatt papier
aufgeschrieben wie der andere in sein
telefonat unterbringen muss haben zudem
haben wir uns auch für den anderen ein
unternehmen rausgesucht bzw einen anruf
den er alle tätigen müssen wir stecken
jetzt erst mal mehr anfangen muss schere
stein papier also wir haben hier meinen
zettel darauf geben die wunderschönen
wörter monopoly nein ich wusste final
original dann burger partie es hat auch
überhaupt nichts nützen dann natürlich
krank und als antwort kommt micro-usb
zwar nie und soja und reis und was ist
das unternehmen wohl anrufen muss nein
das heißt ich werde jetzt hier bei
microsoft anrufen beim handy und max mit
nebenbei mit dem edding die wörter
durchstreichen die ich dann geschafft
hat zu erwähnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
60 plätze pro anruf auf dem deutschen
mobilfunk abhängig vom anbieter
dort möchten oder probleme microsoft war
vielleicht ein bisschen zu krass die
machen jetzt folgendes berufs bitte
einen lieferservice an einen
lieferservice
ja hallo hier ist gründer tom kranich
habe eine frage und zwar habe ich die
tage bei euch bestellt und mir war das
jetzt essen nachhinein aufgefallen weil
ich hatte die bestellung bekommen und in
der tüte war ein war die rechnung noch
mit drin und da stand auch alles raus
gestellt hatte also reist mit sojasoße
und so einen burger kette und so was
alles aber da stand alles zweimal drauf
also das ganze hat irgendwie ich weiß
nicht ob und zwar nicht gekostet
eigentlich aber das stand dann dass es
irgendwie 40 euro kosten wird und mir
war es in dem moment gar nicht
aufgefallen
[Musik]
das war über das konto von einem freund
ich weiß nicht also ich hatte damals ein
ladekabel wollte ich mein handy über
microsd der aufladen aber deswegen
hatten wir das was ein und bestellt ich
habe jetzt gerade gar nicht sonst würde
ich mich einfach nach hameln wir sind
halt gerade noch an monopoly spielen
dann würde ich mich einfach mal nicht
wenn du
wenn die kollegen
ok also quasi einfach eine mail über das
kontaktformular dann an euch und ok gut
machen
ok super danke danke zu sagen nein ich
gesagt nein ich darf ist alles
durchgestrichen eine für ihn ein mega
gewaltiger das war unserer greife ich
habe mich richtig gefreut der typ hat
glaube ich nicht mehr erahnen können das
ist irgendwie sowas später ich bin
gerade produkte
der anfang soll ich bin gunnar konnte
max jetzt bist du hier an der reihe
freust du dich schon ja deine wörter
sind ladekabel gestorben
ok aufgestanden krankhafter geburtstag
er wusste ding 110 socken und
muskelkater
du musst anrufen bei einer druckerei in
düsseldorf bei einer druckerei
aber mein laden aviv geschlagen tag hier
max grad und nicht ruf an war ich
letztens bei ihnen eine bachelorarbeit
drucken lassen habe die habe ich auch
abgegeben alles super gewesen jetzt
meine frau meine mutter demnächst
geburtsland ich wollte die nochmal
ausdrucken lassen ich habe jetzt keinen
gehabt jetzt auf einem speichermedium
mehr kann ich irgendwie einfach da mein
handy mit einem radikal mitnimmt es vom
handy aus drucken eine sache noch gerade
so 1 2 druck schwierigkeiten zwar
einzelne wörter
gestorben auferstanden aufgestanden das
ist jetzt eigentlich unabhängig vom wort
aber die hatten irgendwie sowie waren so
leicht verschwommen kann man das
irgendwie durch eine höhere
druckqualität vielleicht für ein
geschenk aus besser ja also es ist halt
immer eine bachelorarbeit gut wie auch
immer ich wollte frei haben sie auch
möglichkeit textildruck zu machen
beispielsweise auf socken oder so ja
irgendwo irgendwelche textilien können
sie können sie das auch kein plan können
sie auch eine socke das wort muskelkater
drücken oder so gut sei entscheidend
sondern schreibe ich irgendwie ist jetzt
nur ein kleines geschenk für den freund
schreibe ich mit mit edding drauf und
dann wird der kreislauf der einzelnen 0
und erfasst hat ok ich denk mal für ein
geburtstag ist wahrscheinlich ein
hardcover passend dann melde ich mich
vielen dank dass es gut war wusste lang
essen
ich habe das nicht gesehen weil es durch
gestellt ich habe auch nicht gesehen war
das alles die griechen war dem riesch
lag ist dass einige wörter verschwommen
gedrückt waren alter das war das war
richtiger das war das paket sieht man
warum hast du nicht geschieht der kölner
aussagen ja hier ich habe ihnen was zu
essen bestellt und auch meiner küche
stand so komische wörter darauf dass ich
darauf monopoly urinal burger réthy hast
du dem nicht so sei es mit nürnberg über
typisch der hilfe das hat sie auf jeden
fall von video meine damen und herren
wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen
wir wollten mal sondern extreme anruf
halten challenge machen also nicht dass
man einfach irgendeinen youtuber anruft
und die stimme verstellen muss sondern
bei ihnen im unternehmen anruft und in
welche wörter unterbringen soll wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ihr eine revanche
wollte last man leichter und bei
wikileaks kommt eine revanche bei 22
das war nie likes alter last zwar nix da
dann machen wir eine revanche
das was jetzt hier kombi oder das was
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemand den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job aus schenkungen jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und
managen abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]